This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. On the surface, people around the world lead very different lives. Some live in bustling cities, others in tiny villages. Some are part of vast intergenerational households, others live on their own. People in different countries follow a bewildering range of religious traditions, but atheism is also on the rise in many places. When anthropologists look beneath the surface however, they often find that humans around the world are very similar. They invoke supernatural forces when it looks like
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。表面上看，世界各地的人们过着截然不同的生活。有些人住在繁华的大都市，另一些人住在偏远的小村庄。有些人属于庞大的几世同堂家庭，另一些人则独居。不同国家的风俗习惯遵循着令人眼花缭乱的宗教传统，但无神论在许多地方也在抬头。然而，当人类学家深入表象之下时，他们往往会发现世界各地的人类其实非常相似。当看似
their sports teams might lose. They take part in annual festivals that demand time, effort, and money. They mark important moments, such as marriages, births, and deaths, with intricately choreographed scripts. These festivals, rights, and scripts are so much a part of all our lives that few of us stop to ask why we perform them. This week on Hidden Brain, theata works at the University of Connecticut. His research
他们的运动队可能会输时，他们会祈求超自然力量。他们参加需要时间、精力和金钱的年度节日。他们用精心编排的剧本标记重要时刻，例如婚礼、出生和死亡。这些节日、仪式和剧本如此深深融入我们的生活，以至于我们很少有人停下来问问为什么要举行它们。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，迪米特里·齐科拉塔斯在康涅狄格大学工作。他的研究
has taken him across the planet. In his travels, Dmitri has found common cultural practices among people living in far-flung places. Many of these practices involve dangerous, difficult, or expensive rituals. The rituals themselves are often dramatic. They are also regularly incomprehensible to outsiders. But when you peer beneath the surface, rituals actually reveal a great deal about the human mind and the psychological features that people around the world haven't common. Dimitri Zikolatas, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hi, Shankar. Thank you for inviting me.
带他走遍了全球。在旅行中，迪米特里发现在遥远地方生活的人们之间存在着共同的文化习俗。其中许多习俗涉及危险、困难或昂贵的仪式。仪式本身往往充满戏剧性。局外人也常常无法理解它们。但当你深入表象之下时，仪式实际上揭示了关于人类心灵以及世界各地人们共同拥有的心理特征的很多信息。迪米特里·齐科拉塔斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。你好，尚卡尔。谢谢你邀请我。
Dimitri, some years ago, you found yourself in the Spanish village of San Pedro, Manrique, and you met a man named Alejandro. How did you first come into contact with him? So I was doing a research on fire working rituals in Greece. That was for my doctoral research. And after that, I found out that there's another place in Europe where fire working rituals are performed. And this is the small village called San Pedro Enrique.
迪米特里，几年前，你发现自己身处西班牙圣佩德罗-曼里克村，你遇到了一位名叫亚历杭德罗的男士。你是怎么最初与他取得联系的？当时我正在希腊研究走火仪式。那是我的博士研究。之后，我发现欧洲还有另一个地方也在举行走火仪式。这就是那个叫圣佩德罗-恩里克的小村庄。
So I just showed up there. I started asking people if they knew about this ritual and as it turns out It was a really big deal in that community. So one of the first people Who others pointed me to was Alejandra People hold him in very high esteem in that village because he's one of the oldest fire workers And he in fact has been doing this ritual for many decades So I understand that he was in his 70s when you were talking with him. Can you paint me a detailed picture of the of the fire walking ritual as it was practiced
所以我刚好出现在那里。我开始问人们是否知道这个仪式，结果发现这在那个社区里是一件非常重要的大事。因此，其他人指给我的最初几个人之一就是亚历杭德罗。村民们对他非常敬重，因为他是最年长的走火者之一，而且事实上他已经进行这个仪式几十年了。据我了解，你跟他交谈时他已经70多岁了。你能给我详细描述一下当时实行的走火仪式吗？
in this small Spanish village? We are talking about a village of 600 inhabitants. That is in the middle of pretty much nowhere. And yet people have built this large open amphitheater that can host 3000 spectators. Wow and they only use it once a year for the purposes of this ritual. So clearly this is very important to them. On the summer solstice, every June, people start gathering in the central square. They engage in all kinds of processions and other celebrations throughout the day. And in the evening, they all join hands and they form this human chain.
在这个西班牙小村庄里？我们讨论的是一个只有600名居民的村庄。那个地方可以说是鸟不拉屎。然而人们却建造了这个能容纳3000名观众的大型露天圆形剧场。哇，他们一年只为了这个仪式的目的使用一次。所以显然这对他们非常重要。在每年六月的夏至，人们开始聚集在中央广场。他们全天进行各种游行和其他庆祝活动。到了晚上，大家手拉手结成这样的人链。
And they start marching up the hill and lockstep towards that venue. And once everybody takes their place, at exactly midnight, people start taking off their shoes, and they face a large pit of coals. This has been produced by two tons of awkward that has been burning for hours. And it forms this bed of glowing coals. We actually measured the temperatures there at 1,200 Fahrenheit. That's enough to melt aluminum. My gosh. And while faced with this bear of course,
他们开始迈着整齐的步伐朝山上的那个场地进发。当每个人都就位后，正好在午夜，人们开始脱掉鞋子，面对一个巨大的煤炭坑。这是由两吨燃烧了数小时的橡木产生的。它形成了这层发光的煤炭。我们实际测量那里的温度达到了1200华氏度。这足以融化铝。我的天哪。面对着这堆熊熊燃烧的煤炭，
they take somebody on their back and they walk barefoot across it, on the burning fire. What a beautiful day! What a beautiful day! What a beautiful day! Wow, and this was true of Alejandro as well. He would carry someone across this better fire.
他们把一个人背在背上，光着脚走过去，穿过燃烧的火焰。多么美好的一天！多么美好的一天！多么美好的一天！哇，亚历杭德罗也是如此。他会背着人走过这片火海。
Correct. In fact, one time when I saw him carry his niece, who was significantly larger than him, Alejandro is a tiny man. So, he struggled to balance her on his soldiers. People offered to help him, but then he just waved his hand and he went through and did it. You once asked Alejandro if he would ever stop engaging in this ritual, I want to play you a clip of what he said in Spanish. Can you translate what he told you, Dimitris? He looked at me, he thought about it for a while, and he says, well, I suppose that they will come. But when he does, he says, I will just not go up there.
没错。事实上，有一次我看到他背着他的侄女，侄女比他魁梧得多，亚历杭德罗是个瘦小的男子。所以，他在肩膀上平衡她很吃力。人们提出帮他，但他只是挥了挥手，然后就走过去完成了。你曾经问过亚历杭德罗是否会停止参与这个仪式，我想放一段他在说西班牙语的录音片段。迪米特里，你能翻译一下他跟你说了什么吗？他看着我，思考了一会儿，然后说，好吧，我想这一天会来的。但当它到来时，他说，我只是不会去那里。
And I said, what do you mean? He said, well, I cannot go there, because if I do that, if I saw it without being able to do it, I would climb on the belt tower and jump off and kill myself. So the following year Alejandro got some news from his doctor. What was it, DeityMetres? I heard from Alejandro's son, Mamel, that his doctor told him he had detected some arrhythmia and his heart and therefore he banned him from doing the ritual. But things took a dramatic turn that night. I was in the central square with his son, preparing for the procession that would lead us to the venue.
我说，你什么意思？他说，好吧，我不能去那里，因为如果我去了，如果我看到自己无法做到这一点，我会爬上钟楼跳下去自杀。所以第二年亚历杭德罗从他的医生那里得到了一个消息。是什么消息，迪米特里？我从亚历杭德罗的儿子马梅尔那里听说，他的医生告诉他，检测到他的心脏有某种心律失常，因此禁止他参加这个仪式。但那天晚上事情发生了戏剧性的转折。我和他的儿子在中央广场，为将引导我们前往场地的游行做准备。
And at some point, Mamel pulled me out of the chain. I said, what's happening? Mamel says, come with me and you'll see. So he took me to his father's house and he announced, he said, Dad, I know you cannot do the ritual, so I'm going to carry you through the fire. And Alejandro just looked at him for a few seconds, he hugged him and then they cried together. He hugged him and then they cried together. So we left the house and we walked towards the venue. And indeed, Mamel was one of the first persons to walk across the fire. He took off his shoes, he took his father on his back, and he crossed the burning coast.
在某个时刻，马梅尔把我拉出了队伍。我说，怎么了？马梅尔说，跟我来，你就知道了。于是他把我带到他父亲的家里并宣布说，爸爸，我知道你不能参加仪式了，所以我要背着你穿过火海。亚历杭德罗只是看着他几秒钟，拥抱了他，然后他们一起哭了。他拥抱了他，然后他们一起哭了。于是我们离开房子，走向场地。事实上，马梅尔确实是第一个走过火海的人之一。他脱下鞋子，把父亲背在背上，穿过了燃烧的煤炭。
At that point, the crowd was extenent. Everybody was cheering. His family rushed to hike him. But then suddenly Alejandro turned towards them and with a sharp gesture he told them to stop. Everybody went completely silent, 3,000 people. You could hear a pin drop as Alejandro turned around, facing the fire, and he just went ahead and crossed it again, biting himself this time. All right, all right. You say it again.
当时，人群欣喜若狂。每个人都在欢呼。他的家人冲上去拥抱他。但突然亚历杭德罗转向他们，用一个严厉的手势示意他们停下来。全场鸦雀无声，三千人寂静无声。当亚历杭德罗转过身面对火焰时，甚至能听到一根针掉落的声音，他竟然径这次独自一人再次穿过去，这次他自己咬牙坚持。好啦，好啦。你再说一遍。
Yeah. Yeah. Go, go. Go, go. Go, go. You talked to Alejandro about his choice to endanger his heart against his doctor's advice. What did he tell you afterwards to make sure?
是的。是的。走，走。走，走。走，走。你和亚历杭德罗谈过他选择违背医嘱拿自己的心脏冒险的决定。为了弄明白，他后来对你说了什么？
It was actually not the first time I've heard this from a far walker. He said something like, my doctor said that if I do the far walk, something terrible might happen to my heart. But does he know what will happen to my heart if I don't do the far walk? You know, it seems almost that there is a theme that shows up again and again in your research into rituals. When you look at them from the outside, they can seem incomprehensible bewildering, but
其实这不是我第一次从走火者那里听到这话。他说过这样的话：我的医生说，如果我走火，我的心脏可能会发生可怕的事情。但如果我不走火，他又怎么知道我的心脏会发生什么呢？你知道，在你的仪式研究中，似乎总有一个主题反复出现。当你从外部看它们时，它们可能显得不可思议、令人困惑，但
seen from the inside, the people who practiced these rituals really cherish them, even when they carry significant costs. And in some ways, that's what you were hearing from Alejandro, wasn't it? Absolutely. Yes, across all kinds of different contexts, they carry so much meaning that people consider them to be a fundamental part of who they are as individuals and an equally fundamental part of their collective identity, who they are as group members. So we've looked at one example of a ritual that carried enormous physical risks, but of course, rituals also carry other forms of risks and other, another costs, tell us what pilgrims endure during the Kummela festival in India.
从内部来看，实践这些仪式的人们确实非常珍惜它们，即使它们伴随着巨大的代价。从某种意义上说，这就是你从亚历杭德罗那里听到的，不是吗？绝对是。是的，在各种不同的语境中，它们承载着如此丰富的意义，以至于人们认为它们是作为个体的核心部分，同样也是作为群体成员的集体身份的核心部分。所以我们看了承载巨大身体风险的仪式的例子，但当然，仪式也承载着其他形式的风险和其他代价，跟我们讲讲朝圣者在印度的「大壶节」期间经受了什么。
The Kummela is one of the most important Hindu pilgrimages in the world. And this is arguably the biggest congregation of human beings in known history. Last time somebody counted, there were about 150 million people attending the festivities. It takes place every 12 years and it happens on the banks of four sacred rivers, the Ganges being one of them, and people might take several weeks to travel there from all parts of India and beyond, and when they reach it the festival lasts for a month. Some people actually stay for the entire month. And during that month, you can imagine in such an incredibly crowded place, people live in tents.
大壶节是世界上最重要的印度教朝圣活动之一。可以说这是已知历史上最大规模的人类聚集。上次有人统计时，大约有1.5亿人参加了庆祝活动。它每12年举行一次，发生在四条圣河的河岸上，恒河是其中之一，人们可能需要花几周时间从印度各地及以外的地方赶到那里，当他们到达时，节日会持续一个月。实际上有些人会待满整整一个月。在那一个月里，你可以想象在这样一个极其拥挤的地方，人们住在帐篷里。
They bathe in the river, they drink from the river, and the ganges is possibly the most polluted river on earth. So there's definitely a high risk of infectious diseases spreading. It's very hot during the day, but it's freezing cold during the night. So this ritual is full of hearts. I mean, at a more prosaic level, you've also studied rituals that are just financially costly and many rituals fall under this category. Certainly, staying in a place like India, there are many families in India who celebrate weddings
他们在河里洗澡，从河里喝水，而恒河可能是地球上污染最严重的河流。因此，传染病传播的高风险绝对是存在的。白天非常热，但晚上冷得结冰。所以这个仪式充满了各种艰辛。我的意思是，从更世俗的层面来看，你也研究过纯粹在财务上付出高昂代价的仪式，许多仪式都属于这一类别。当然，留在像印度这样的地方，印度的许多家庭通过
by going into extreme debt. Can you talk about that, Dimitri? This is something that is actually very similar to what I've seen in my home country. I come from Greece, so in rural areas of Greece, certainly when I was younger, when I was a kid, I've seen many instances of people going into debt to finance their children's wedding.
背负极端债务来庆祝婚礼。迪米特里，你能谈谈这个吗？这实际上与我在我的祖国看到的非常相似。我来自希腊，所以在希腊的农村地区，当然在我年轻的时候，当我还是个孩子的时候，我见过许多人为孩子们的婚礼筹资而陷入债务的例子。
In India, there's this local NGO which estimated over 60% of all Indian households they turn to money lenders in order to finance their children's weddings. And of course, they have to pay extortion and rates. And in many cases, they will sign contracts that get them into voluntary servitude over a period of years. So, intensive labor to be able to pay those debts off. So, hearing about these ordeals, people on the outside might wonder, why would anyone
在印度，有这样一个当地的非政府组织估计，超过60%的印度家庭为了筹集子女的婚礼资金而求助于高利贷者。当然，他们必须支付盘剥性的利率。在许多情况下，他们会签署契约，使自己陷入为期数年的契约奴役中。也就是说，通过繁重的体力劳动来偿还这些债务。因此，听到这些磨难，局外人可能会纳闷，为什么会有人
voluntarily go through such hardship? And one thing you've done is actually ask participants that very question, and you've discovered a paradox when you ask someone like Alejandro or a pilgrim in the cummele, why they do what they do? What do they tell you, Dimitris? I have asked hundreds, if not thousands of people, this question. Why do you do your rituals in general, or why do you do this particular ritual? And one of the most astonishing things that never sees to you, amaze me, is that even in the case of rituals that involve extraordinary material costs, physical effort, physical
自愿经历这样的苦难？而你所做的事情之一，其实就是向参与者提出这个问题，当你问像亚历杭德罗或大壶节的朝圣者他们为什么这样做时，你发现了一个悖论。他们对你说了什么，迪米特里？我问过成百上千的人这个问题。你为什么一般要举行仪式，或者你为什么举行这个特定的仪式？最令人惊奇、让我永不厌倦的事情之一就是，即使在涉及巨额物质代价、体力付出、身体风险的仪式中，大多数人也只是看着我说，你什么意思，为什么要做我们的仪式？这就是我们所做的。这就是我们是谁。你称之为仪式悖论，为我剖析一下这个想法。
risks, most people would just look at me and say, what do you mean, why would you do our rituals? This is just what we do. This is who we are. You call this the ritual paradox, unpacked that idea for me. So the paradox is that on the one hand, people attribute tremendous meaning and importance to those rituals. Sometimes they will tell me this is the most important event of their lives. And yet, when I ask them why they do it, they very often cannot come up with an answer. So you had first-hand experience of what it was like to participate in one of these rituals. When
所以这个悖论在于，一方面，人们将巨大的意义和重要性赋予这些仪式。有时他们会告诉我，这是他们一生中最重大的事件。然而，当我问他们为什么要这么做时，他们往往想不出答案。所以你对参与其中一个仪式有着第一手的体验。当
you were a small boy growing up in Greece. I understand when you were eight years old, your dad took you on an important, let's call it an expedition. Can you describe where he took you and what you saw? So this was a football stadium. And by football, I mean, what in the United States people call soccer, which in many parts of the world, my home country included can be an almost religious-like activity. People have very strong loyal tears towards their team. So at eight years old, I went into a stadium packed with 45,000 people. And I noticed that as soon as the game started, everybody jumped up and never sat down again. And what followed from that moment
你在希腊度过童年时。我听说在你八岁的时候，你爸爸带你进行了一次重要的，我们可以称之为探险的活动。你能描述一下他带你去了哪里以及你看到了什么吗？所以这是一个足球场。说到足球，我的意思是美国人所说的soccer，在世界许多地方，包括我的祖国，这几乎可以是一项类似宗教的活动。人们对他们的球队有非常强烈的忠诚感。所以八岁时，我走进了一个挤满了45,000人的体育场。我注意到比赛一开始，所有人就都跳了起来，再也没有坐下。从那一刻起接踵而至的是
on was one of the most unbelievable experiences of my young life. People lit thousands of flares and torches and fireworks and the entire stadium turning to this ball of fire. It really looked like a volcano. People chanting and synchronizing, jumping up and down and synchronizing, lighting those flares, which of course meant that as soon as the game started, it had to be paused for several minutes just for the air to clear. And my father kept picking me up so that I could watch the game, but I didn't even care about it. All I cared about was all of those incredible collective rituals that were happening around me.
我年轻时最不可思议的经历之一。人们点燃了成千上万的信号弹、火把和烟花，整个体育场变成了一个巨大的火球。它看起来真像一座火山。人们齐声歌唱，同步跳上跳下，点燃这些信号弹，这当然意味着比赛一开始，就必须暂停几分钟以便空气恢复清晰。我父亲一直把我抱起来，这样我就可以看比赛，但我根本不在乎比赛。我关心的只是周围发生的那些不可思议的集体仪式。
So as I was hearing the story Demetrius, I was sort of seeing the eight-year-old version of you essentially becoming an anthropologist before our eyes, observing all the people around you and asking why they were doing what they were doing. But it's also the case that you became a fan of the sport, but also of this particular team. See, most people, they don't show up at the temple when they're eight years old, just because they had an internal yearning to worship. Typically, they're parents think them. But it is through the act of participation itself that one becomes religious or becomes a fan, that one gets bonded with this group of people.
所以当我听到这个故事时，迪米特里，我仿佛看到了八岁的你在我们眼前变成了一名人，观察着你周围的所有人，并问他们为什么在做他们正在做的事情。但事实也是，你不仅成为了这项运动的球迷，也成为了这支特定球队的球迷。看，大多数人八岁时出现在寺庙里，并不是因为他们内心有崇拜的渴望。通常是他们的父母带他们去的。但正是在参与的行为本身中，一个人才变得笃信宗教或成为球迷，一个人才与这群人建立起紧密的联系。
Because when people come together and they engage in all those kinds of ecstatic like rituals, this conglomeration of individuals ceases to be that and suddenly it becomes one unified group. And even from the perspective of an eight-year-old looking at this group, that's exactly what it seemed like. It ceased to be 45,000 individuals and it was simply one large pulsating unity that was chanting and it was jumping up and down together as if it was a single organism. And I was part of it. When we come back, the psychology of how and why rituals affect us so deeply. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
因为当人们聚集在一起，参与所有这些狂喜般的仪式时，这个由个人组成的集合体就不再是那样了，突然间变成了一个统一的群体。即使从一个八岁孩子的角度看着这个群体，这正是它的样子。它不再是45,000个个体，而是一个巨大而有节奏脉动的整体，大家一起歌唱，一起跳上跳下，仿佛是一个单一的有机体。而我是其中的一部分。广告回来后，我们将探讨仪式如何以及为什么对我们产生如此深远影响的心理学。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. At the University of Connecticut, anthropologist Dmitri Zikalatas has found that rituals exact significant costs in time, money, even pain and suffering from the people who practice them. Irrational economists might say it would make more sense for people to make sacrifices for activities that improve their lives in some tangible way. But everywhere and in every age, including our own, people divert significant attention to seemingly ceremonial activities. Dimitrius you call this the ritual paradox from the outside,
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在康涅狄格大学，人类学家迪米特里·齐科拉塔斯发现，仪式从实践它们的人身上索取了时间、金钱甚至痛苦和折磨方面的巨大代价。不理智的经济学家可能会说，人们为以某种切实方式改善生活的活动做出牺牲会更有意义。但在任何地方和任何时代，包括我们这个时代，人们都将大量的注意力转移到看似流于形式的活动上。迪米特里，你称之为仪式悖论。从外部来看，
ritual seen pointless, and yet they are experienced by participants as something truly vital. In your book, ritual, how seemingly senseless acts make life worth living, you say that it's a mistake to think of rituals as primarily being about what we do in the outside world. The real purpose of rituals is for us to hack into our own inner worlds? Absolutely. And the idea is that just because ritual does not have any immediate, direct effects on the physical world, this does not mean that it has no impact at all. In fact, it has a huge impact on our internal world, the way we perceive ourselves, the way we feel, the way we connect with other people, and ultimately our well-being and our quality of life. So one immediate question is why we need to do this, because after all we are capable of
仪式显得毫无意义，然而参与者却将其体验为真正至关重要的东西。在你的书《仪式：看似无意义的行为如何让生命值得过》中，你提到把仪式主要看作我们在外部世界所做的事情是一个错误。仪式的真正目的是让我们深入我们自己的内心世界？绝对是的。这个想法是，仅仅因为仪式对物理世界没有任何直接的即时影响，这并不意味着它完全没有影响。事实上，它对我们的内心世界、我们看待自己的方式、我们的感受方式、我们与他人联系的方式，以及最终对我们的福祉和生活质量有着巨大的影响。所以一个直接的问题是我们为什么需要这样做，因为毕竟我们有能力进行
introspection, we're capable of reflection. There are a lot of ways that we can talk to our internal cells. What is it about the challenges we face in life that prompt us to do things on the outside, things like walking across a bed of fire to change what's happening inside our own minds? Well, the simple answer here could be because it simply works. Sometimes we don't really have to understand that a particular behavior helps us reduce anxiety or cope with grief or connect with other people, but viscerally
内省，我们有能力进行反思。有很多方法我们可以与我们的内在自我对话。我们生活中面临的挑战究竟是什么，促使我们在外部做一些事情，比如走过火海来改变我们自己心智里面发生的事情？嗯，这里简单的回答可能是因为它确实有效。有时我们不一定非要理解某种特定行为有助于我们减少焦虑、应对悲伤或与他人建立联系，但从内脏般的直觉上
it does so. So when we go out and we dance and sing with our friends, we don't stop to ask the question, why are we doing this? Isn't dancing pointless? And yet, there's a fundamental function to act like dancing or singing or celebrating or performing any kind of ritual together. One of the really interesting ideas that you and others explore is that there is something of a mismatch between the minds that have been handed down to us by evolution, our physical brain, and the challenges that were often called to address in the actual world.
它确实起到了这样的作用。所以当我们外出与朋友载歌载舞时，我们不会停下来问这个问题，我们为什么要这样做？跳舞难道没有意义吗？然而，像跳舞、唱歌、庆祝或共同表演任何形式的仪式这样的行为，都有着基本的功能。你和其他人探讨的非常有趣的观点之一是，演化传给我们的心智（我们的生理大脑）与我们在真实世界中常常被要求应对的挑战之间，存在着某种不匹配。
And I'm not a fan of the idea that the brain is like a computer, because the metaphor is not exact. But if you were to think about the brain as a computer, it's almost as if this computer was designed to solve a set of problems, but the problems have now changed in some dramatic way. And we have a software patch that can essentially get this older computer to function in this newer environment. Is that the connection that you would make with rituals? That rituals in some ways are functioning like a software patch? Yes, that's a good analogy, I think. And one example would be the way we handle stress and anxiety. Stress is a useful thing. It's an adaptive response. It motivates our behavior.
我不喜欢把大脑比作计算机的想法，因为这个隐喻并不精确。但如果你把大脑想象成一台计算机，几乎就像这台计算机是为了解决一组问题而设计的，但这些问题现在已经发生了某种戏剧性的变化。而我们有一个软件补丁，基本上可以让这台旧计算机在这样一个较新的环境中运行。你会把这个与仪式联系起来吗？仪式在某种程度上就像一个软件补丁在发挥作用？是的，我认为这是一个很好的类比。一个例子就是我们处理压力和焦虑的方式。压力是一件有用的事。它是一种适应性反应。它激发我们的行为。
It motivates us to seek solutions, to avoid certain things that are stressful to us. But in the modern context, we see that levels of anxiety are higher than ever. That's because our environment has changed, not our biology. We're living a life that is way faster than anything our ancestors would have experienced. We're living in social contexts where most of us, or many of us at least, live very far away, removed from our social support networks, our family, our best friends. We move around, we live with anonymous strangers, and all that can be very stressful. So by finding ways of soothing these kinds of anxieties and
它激励我们寻求解决方案，避免某些给我们带来压力的事物。但在现代背景下，我们发现焦虑水平比以往任何时候都高。那是因为我们的环境变了，而不是我们的生物学变了。我们的生活节奏比祖先经历过的任何事情都要快得多。我们生活在这样的社会环境中：我们大多数人，或者至少我们中的许多人，住得很远，远离了我们的社会支持网络、家人、最好的朋友。我们四处奔波，与匿名的陌生人生活在一起，所有这些都可能压力极大。因此，通过寻找舒缓这些焦虑和
these kinds of pressures, we might be able to solve these new problems that our biology has not had time to solve. This is an old idea that goes all the way back to an anthropologist called Bronisl of Malinovsky. Malinovsky noticed that in the Trobra and Islands, the Pacific Ocean, where he was doing his field work, the local fisherman would perform a lot of rituals before going out to fish in the open sea, but not before going out to fish in the shallow waters of the lagoon. Now, he's realised that this was because fishing in the ocean is dangerous, it's stressful, and it's uncertain. You never know what you're going to catch. You never know if you're even going to come back alive, if you have to battle the waves and hunt sharks and whales.
这些压力的方法，我们或许能够解决这些我们的生物学还没有时间解决的新问题。这是一个古老的想法，一直追溯到一位名叫布罗尼斯瓦夫·马利诺夫斯基的人类学家。马利诺夫斯基注意到，在他在太平洋特罗布里恩群岛进行实地考察时，当地的渔民在去公海捕鱼之前会举行许多仪式，但在泻湖浅水区捕鱼之前则不会。现在，他意识到这是因为在海洋中捕鱼是危险的、充满压力的且不确定的。你永远不知道你能捕到什么。如果你必须与海浪搏斗并猎捕鲨鱼和鲸鱼，你甚至不知道自己是否还能活着回来。
And this is a theory that has been taught to unspull the students for about a century, but there was very little evidence to support it. Within the last couple of decades, we now have tangible evidence that ritual actually helps alleviate anxiety. One of these studies took place on the Indian Ocean Island of Mauritius. Tell me about that experiment, Dimitris, and what you found. For this study, we went into a small fishing village, and there's a Hindu temple there. The local women will visit this temple frequently, and they will perform these prayers. They consist of repetitive movements, performed in front of several statues of the Hindu pan-film. And before going in there, we used an anxiety inducing technique.
这是一个教给大学生的理论，已经有一个世纪了，但支持它的证据却很少。在过去的几十年里，我们现在有了切实的证据表明仪式确实有助于缓解焦虑。其中一项研究是在印度洋的毛里求斯岛上进行的。迪米特里，跟我讲讲那个实验，以及你发现了什么。为了这项研究，我们进入了一个小渔村，那里有一座印度教寺庙。当地的妇女会经常访问这座寺庙，她们会进行这些祈祷。它们由重复的动作组成，在印度教万神殿的几尊雕像前进行。在进入那里之前，我们使用了诱发焦虑的技术。
So we asked them to think about natural disasters like cyclones and floods. And this is very salient to this island because it's very often threatened by such natural disasters. And then we allowed them to do their rituals in their normal way. And we also had a control group who went into a secular space and spent the equivalent amount of time just sitting down. And afterwards, we measured their anxiety levels, both in terms of how they perceived their anxiety
所以我们要求她们思考自然灾害，如气旋和洪水。这对于这个岛屿非常重要，因为它经常受到此类自然灾害的威胁。然后我们允许她们以正常的方式进行仪式。我们还有一个对照组，他们进入一个世俗空间，花等量的时间只是坐着。之后，我们测量了她们的焦虑水平，既包括她们对自身焦虑的感知，
and in terms of what their body said. We measured heart rate variability, which is an indication of our body's ability to cope with stress. And we found that performing this ritual actually helped people reduce their anxiety more than those in the control group. I'm wondering how this actually works inside our minds Dimitris. How is it that rituals can actually soothe people's anxiety? What is it that they are doing, do you think? So the idea that my colleagues and I are proposing here is related to the way our brain works. Our brain is not just a computational machine, it's a predictive machine.
也包括她们身体的反应。我们测量了心率变异性，这是我们身体应对压力能力的指标。我们发现进行这项仪式实际上比对照组更能帮助人们降低焦虑。迪米特里，我想知道这在我们的心智内部到底是如何运作的。仪式究竟是如何安抚人们的焦虑的？你认为他们在做什么？我和我的同事在这里提出的观点与我们大脑的工作方式有关。我们的大脑不仅仅是一台计算机器，它是一台预测机器。
It makes active inferences about the state of the world. Our brain does this in all kinds of contexts and all the time. This is a very useful cognitive architecture to have, of course. But one byproduct of that architecture, one side effect is that when there's uncertainty in the world where we cannot make accurate predictions, we experience anxiety. And we think this is exactly where Richel comes in, because if Richel is anything, it is structure. It is predictability. When I engage in a Richel, I know exactly what to do, and I know exactly when to do it, and how. And this gives my brain a sense of control.
它对世界的状态进行积极的推断。我们的大脑在各种背景下一直都在这样做。当然，拥有这种认知架构是非常有用的。但该架构的一个副产品，一个副作用是，当世界上存在不确定性、我们无法做出准确预测时，我们会感到焦虑。我们认为这正是仪式发挥作用的地方，因为如果仪式有什么特点的话，那就是结构。它是可预测性。当我参与仪式时，我知道该做什么，我也确切地知道什么时候做以及如何做。这给了我的大脑一种掌控感。
And at the end of the day, it doesn't matter whether this sense of control is real or illusory, as long as it has tangible effects, and we do see that it does. There's been research showing that performing rituals doesn't just make people feel better, it can actually lead to better outcomes. One study investigated the effect of a made-up ritual on people's performance in a stressful activity. Can you tell me what that study found images? Yes, this was a study performed by Alison Brooks who asked people to prepare in order to engage in a series of stressful tasks. Those were tasks like taking a math test or participating in a public karaoke competition. So the researchers asked participants
归根结底，这种掌控感是真实的还是虚幻的并不重要，只要它具有切实的效果，而我们确实看到它做到了。研究表明，举行仪式不仅能让人感觉更好，实际上还能带来更好的结果。一项研究调查了虚构的仪式对人们在压力活动中表现的影响。迪米特里，你能告诉我那项研究发现了什么吗？是的，这是艾莉森·布鲁克斯进行的一项研究，她要求人们为一系列压力任务做好准备。这些任务就像参加数学测试或参加公共卡拉OK比赛。因此，研究人员要求参与者
either performer artificial ritual, which resembled a magical spell, or perform no ritual. The ritual was consistently enjoying a picture of how they're feeling right now and then sprinkling the insult on the picture, counting up to five, and then ritual destroying the paper. What they found was that performing this type of ritual helped people actually perform better. So they evaluated the carotchee performances or the mathematical tests so that people were able to perform better. And of course, not through some kind of magical causation. When they looked at the mediating factors, they found that it was through their reduction
要么表演一种类似于魔法咒语的人工仪式，要么不进行仪式。该仪式始终包括画一幅关于他们目前的感受的画，然后将侮辱洒在画上，数到五，然后以仪式化的方式毁掉纸张。他们发现，进行这种类型的仪式实际上有助于人们表现得更好。因此，他们评估了卡拉OK表演或数学测试，发现人们能够表现得更好。当然，这不是通过某种神奇的因果关系。当他们查看中介因素时，他们发现正是通过减少焦虑和增强掌控感，他们才能够提高表现。
of anxiety and an increase sense of control that they were able to improve their performance. So, we've looked at different ways in which rituals might help us address questions of uncertainty, questions of stress. Another problem of living that rituals address is the pain of loss and grief. Dimitris, can you help us understand why there are so many rituals associated with death and dying? Every human society we've known has had elaborate burial rituals. Now, why is that? Well, this again has to do with the way our brain works. We are hypersocial animals, and as hypersocial animals, we have a number of particularly strong forms of attachment.
所以，我们探讨了仪式可能帮助我们解决不确定性问题、压力问题的不同方式。生活面临的另一个问题与失去和悲伤的痛苦有关。迪米特里，你能帮我们理解为什么有这么多与死亡和垂死相关的仪式吗？我们所知道的每一个人类社会都有精细的埋葬仪式。这是为什么呢？嗯，这再次与我们的大脑工作方式有关。我们是超社会动物，作为超社会动物，我们有许多特别强大的依恋形式。
We see, for example, when young children are separated from their parents, they experience what we call separation anxiety. When lovers experience a breakup, they might go through this very painful period. And when we look at it from this perspective, we realize that the capacity to grieve may have stemmed from evolutionary adaptations, but grief itself
例如，我们看到当幼儿与父母分离时，他们会经历我们所说的分离焦虑。当恋人经历分手时，他们可能会经历这段非常痛苦的时期。当我们从这个角度来看待它时，我们意识到悲伤的能力可能源于演化适应，但悲伤本身
is not adaptive. There is an obvious benefit to the child who experiences anxiety when separated from its mother because they can cry for help. But when we lose somebody because they're no longer with us, there's not much else we can do. So from that perspective, grief is not necessarily very adaptive. And to be able to cope with these debilitating emotions, such as the experience of loss and the fear of our mortality,
并不是适应性的。对于与母亲分离时感到焦虑的孩子来说，有一个明显的好处，因为他们可以哭求帮助。但当我们因为某人不再和我们在一起而失去他们时，我们无能为力。从这个角度来看，悲伤不一定是非常具适应性的。为了能够应对这些令人衰弱的情绪，例如失落的体验和对死亡的恐惧，
every human culture has developed a set of rituals. And what do you think these rituals are doing? I mean, is it the case that they're actually emeliorating our grief, channeling our grief in a new direction? What do you think the rituals are accomplishing here? They can make the process of separation from the deceased a little bit more gradual. So they give us time to digest the fact that they're no longer with us.
每一种人类文化都发展出了一套仪式。你认为这些仪式在做什么？我的意思是，它们是否真的在减轻我们的悲伤，将我们的悲伤引导到一个新的方向？你认为仪式在这里实现了什么？它们可以使与死者分离的过程变得更加渐进。所以它们给我们时间去消化他们不再和我们在一起的事实。
And if you look at burial customs throughout the world, you will see a lot of those customs. They involve keeping the deceased in the house for one day, three days, a week, in the case of some tribes even for a year. Another thing they do is that they help keep the deceased alive in our memories. So they now turn them into ancestors, they turn them into beings with which we will interact in the future again through these periodic rituals, we will make offerings for them, and therefore they provide a sense that they're still with us just in some different way. So we've looked at two areas where rituals can be very helpful in managing anxiety and in managing grief.
如果你看看世界各地的埋葬习俗，你会看到很多这样的习俗。它们包括将死者放在家中一天、三天、一周，在某些部落的情况下甚至一年。它们做的另一件事是帮助死者活在我们的记忆中。所以他们现在把他们变成祖先，把他们变成我们在未来将再次通过这些定期仪式进行互动的存在，我们将为他们提供供品，因此它们提供了一种感觉，即他们仍然和我们在一起，只是以某种不同的方式。所以我们看了仪式在管理焦虑和管理悲伤方面非常有用的两个领域。
A third problem of living has to do with the challenges that come from living in groups, getting people to coordinate and cooperate with each other, especially as you point out, in modern societies where large numbers of people are living amongst strangers. How do rituals help us rise to this challenge, Dimitris? This is perhaps the biggest of all sounds as for us, because we are a social species, but once again, we now live in conditions that are very different. So now we live in these very large societies of an animal's strangers, and cooperation is always going to be a problem.
生活的第三个问题与生活在群体中带来的挑战有关，让人们彼此协调和合作，正如你所指出的那样，特别是在大量人口生活在陌生人中间的现代社会。迪米特里，仪式如何帮助我们迎接这一挑战？这也许对我们来说是所有挑战中最大的一项，因为我们是一个社会物种，但再一次，我们现在生活在非常不同的条件下。所以我们现在生活在这些由匿名陌生人组成的大型社会中，合作将永远是一个问题。
And this is why we have more collective rituals than any other animal in order to get people to feel more bonded and cooperate. For example, collective rituals might have people dress in similar ways. Their studies that show that when people appear to be similar, our brain makes inferences that they are indeed similar, because also in nature, people who look like us, they're more likely to be our relatives. Another way is to align our movements. So we move in synchrony, we chant in synchrony. And again, there are studies that show that people who move in synchrony, they feel closer to each other, they are more rapport and they like each other more. Another way is to align our emotions
这就是为什么我们有比任何其他动物都多的集体伙伴仪式，以使人们感到更加紧密地结合并进行合作。例如，集体仪式可能会让人们以类似的方式着装。有研究表明，当人们显得相似时，我们的大脑会推断他们确实相似，因为在自然界中，长得像我们的人更有可能是我们的亲戚。另一种方法是协调我们的动作。所以我们同步移动，我们同步歌唱。同样，有研究表明，同步移动的人彼此感觉更亲密，他们有更多的融洽感，并且更喜欢彼此。另一种方法是当我们的情感相同时
when we feel the same thing. Again, we feel more connected because who are the people that you feel the same things with? Who are the people that you will mourn with and you will laugh and you will cry with? Typically, those are members of your family and your close friends. And by getting anonymous strangers to do those things together, rituals can create the sense of community and likeness. So we've looked at several ways in which
调整我们的情感。同样，我们感觉联系更紧密，因为你对谁有相同的感受？你会和谁一起哀悼，和谁一起笑一起哭？通常，那些是你的家人和密友。通过让匿名陌生人一起做这些事情，仪式可以创造社区感和相似感。所以我们看了几种
rituals can produce social good, but any psychological force that is powerful enough to get people to walk over burning coals can also have bad outcomes. I want you to listen to this news report from CBS News about a student's death in California. Good morning. Noah Domingo's blood alcohol level was more than four times the legal limit. The UC Irvine freshman was found unresponsive
仪式可以产生社会效益的方式，但任何强大到足以让人走过燃烧的煤炭的心理力量也可能带来不好的结果。我想让你听听哥伦比亚广播公司关于加利福尼亚州一名学生死亡的新闻报道。早上好。诺亚·多明哥的血液酒精浓度是法定限制的四倍多。这位加州大学尔湾分校的大一新生被发现没有反应
and the house behind me after a party in January. His father says Noah was taking part in a dangerous and long-standing fraternity ritual, where Noah was compelled to guzzle a so-called family drink to become part of his big brother's family. Dimitrius, talk about the connection between the bonding power of rituals and the initiation rights we see at college fraternities. So these types of rituals, the very intense types of rituals, they actually do carry great risks. And these risks have to outweigh the costs. So if you think of the kinds of contexts in which these rituals would have been used,
在一月份的一个派对后，我身后的房子里。他的父亲说诺亚正在参与一项危险而长期的兄弟会仪式，诺亚被迫狂饮所谓的家庭饮料，以成为他的兄弟会大家庭的一部分。迪米特里，谈谈仪式的凝聚力与我们在大学兄弟会中看到的入会仪式之间的联系。这些类型的仪式，非常激进的仪式，确实带来了巨大的风险。这些风险必须超过成本。因此，如果你想想这些仪式可能被使用的背景，
society is that face more warfare, for example, they have more intense initiation rituals. And it is one thing to go through initiation ritual that involves a lot of pain and suffering even if you're doing this with the elders of your community, your cohort, everybody you grew up with. And that's a ritual that has been performed for a thousand years, so there's a lot of trial and error going on. But when we take those rituals out of context, and we perform them for no good reason, perhaps for fun.
例如面临更多战争的社会，他们有更激进的入会仪式。经历一个涉及大量痛苦和磨难的入会仪式是一回事，即使你与社区的老年人、同龄人、你一起长大的所有人一起这样做。这是一个已经进行了千年的仪式，所以有很多反复试验。但当我们把这些仪式脱离语境，为了好玩而毫无充分理由地表演它们时。
They can become something very different. It's a very different thing to take that ritual out of context, tweak it, and try to use it to get the same benefits in an entirely different setting. One of the things that I find fascinating about your work is that in recent years, you've started to use technology to assist you in understanding how rituals work. And one of the forms of technology you're using are heart monitors. So using heart monitors, you've collected data during the San Pedro Firewalkers.
它们可能会变成非常不同的东西。将该仪式脱离语境、进行调整并试图在完全不同的环境中利用它来获得相同的好处，则是另一回事。关于你的工作，令我着迷的事情之一是，近年来你开始使用技术来帮助你理解仪士是如何运作的。你使用的技术形式之一是心率监测器。因此，使用心率监测器，你在圣佩德罗走火者期间收集了数据。
You found something extraordinary in the heart monitor data when it came to what was happening in different people's bodies at the very same time. What did you find, Dimitris? So this project started from hearing some of the things that people were telling me in some Pedro. Again and again, I heard them say the same thing. They said that when you go out there, there are 3,000 people, but you feel like one. They said things like, I cannot put it into words, they would say.
当谈到不同的人的身体在同一时间发生的事情时，你在心率监测器数据中发现了一些非凡的东西。迪米特里，你发现了什么？所以这个项目始于听到人们在圣佩德罗对我说的一些事情。一次又一次，我听到他们说同样的话。他们说，当你走出去时，有3,000人，但你感觉像一个人。他们说诸如“我无法用言语表达”之类的话。
But there's this feeling of togetherness, like our emotions are aligned. And this to me sounded very much like what early anthropologists had said. Emil Dirkheim described this feeling of collective earth of essence. He described it as if there was this jolt of electricity running through a group of people that congregated and turning them from a group of unrelated individuals into this cohesive group. So I started thinking how do we actually measure this feeling of oneness, this ineffable feeling of emotional alignment and that my participants describe, but nobody has actually demonstrated. So what we did is that we put those monitors on firewokers, but also members of the group who are just watching and even unrelated strangers who had been there just
但有一种团结的感觉，就像我们的情感是一致的。这对我来说听起来很像早期人类学家所说的话。埃米尔·迪尔凯姆描述了这种集体兴奋的感觉。他将其描述为仿佛有一股电流穿过聚集在一起的一群人，将他们从一群不相关的个体转变为这个具有凝聚力的群体。所以我开始思考我们如何实际测量这种合一感、参与者描述但没有人真正证明的这种难以言喻的情感一致感。所以我们所做的是，我们把这些监测器戴在走火者身上，还有那些只是观看的群体成员身上，甚至还有那些刚刚到那里的不相关的陌生人身上。
as curious tourists towards the festival. What we found is that during the ritual their heart rates began to synchronize to a really impressive degree. In fact, they were more synchronous during the ritual where some of them are walking on fire, some are watching, some are preparing for their own walk. They were more synchronous during that time than the time they were marching up the hill in synchrony. But we also find that this effect only holds for group members because we also mapped the social network of the village. So we knew who was related to home and to what degree, whether by blood or by friendship.
作为对节日充满好奇的游客。我们发现，在仪式举行期间，他们的心跳开始以一种非常惊人的程度同步。事实上，在仪式期间，他们的心同步率更高，当时其中一些人在走火炭，一些人在观看，还有一些人在为自己的走火炭做准备。在那个时候，他们的心同步率比他们齐步走上山时的同步率还要高。但我们也发现，这种效应只适用于群体成员，因为我们还绘制了该村的社交网络图。所以我们知道谁和谁有亲缘关系，以及关系的程度，无论是血缘关系还是友谊关系。
And we see that we can actually use the degree of social proximity to predict the degree of physiological synchrony. So this is a fundamentally social phenomenon. When we come back, in an increasingly rational world that looks with suspicion at anything that's max of superstition, how do we harness the psychological power of rituals? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
我们看到，我们实际上可以利用社会亲近度来预测生理同步度。所以这本质上是一个社会现象。稍后回来，在一个日益理性、对任何带有迷信色彩的东西都抱有怀疑态度的世界里，我们该如何利用仪式的心理力量呢？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Anthropologist Dmitri Zigalata is the author of Ritual, how seemingly senseless acts make life worth living. He's founded over a very long span of time, groups of humans in different parts of the world have independently home-dined on the basic elements of rituals that make them effective in manipulating our inner thoughts and feelings. Dmitrius, you found that rituals always display an important characteristic, one that sets them apart from other actions,
人类学家德米特里·齐加拉塔是《仪式：看似无意义的行为如何让生活变得有价值》一书的作者。他发现，在漫长的时间跨度里，世界不同地区的人类群体独立地发现了仪式的基本要素，这些要素能有效地操纵我们内心的想法和感受。德米特里，你发现仪式总是表现出一个重要的特征，这个特征使它们区别于其他行动，
and you call this causal opacity. What do you mean by this idea? And why is such causal opacity important in the performance of rituals? This is one of the key characteristics of ritual. In fact, it goes to the very definition of ritual. Rituals are those actions that have to be performed repeatedly, Richels are those actions that have to be performed repeatedly, and they have some symbolic value, their treatise are special, and yet they either don't have any specific goal, or there's no visible connection between the actions that one undertakes to achieve a goal and the goal itself.
你称之为因果不透明性。你对这个概念是怎么理解的？为什么这种因果不透明性在仪式的执行中如此重要？这是仪式的关键特征之一。事实上，它直接关系到仪式的定义。仪式是那些必须重复进行的行动，仪式是那些必须重复进行的行动，它们具有某种象征价值，它们的轨迹是特殊的，然而它们要么没有任何具体的目标，要么人们为达到目标而采取的行动与目标本身之间没有可见的联系。
So, if I take a shower in order to cleanse myself, there's obvious utility to this. But if I perform a shower, you know, to cleanse myself, there's obvious utility to this. But if I perform a purification ritual that involves perhaps rubbing mud on my hair, there's no clear connection, there's no obvious connection between the action that I'm performing and the outcome that I'm seeking. And this is very important because by virtue of the fact that racial actions are arbitrary, that means that they can now take any kind of symbolic meaning. And this makes them very efficient group markers because if we are the group that rubs
所以，如果我为了清洁自己而洗澡，这有着明显的实用性。但是，如果我洗个澡，你知道的，为了清洁自己，这有着明显的实用性。但是，如果我进行一个净化仪式，可能包括把泥土抹在头发上，这之间就没有明确的联系，我所进行的行动与我所追求的结果之间没有明显的联系。这非常重要，因为由于仪式行动是随意的这一事实，这意味着它们现在可以承载任何种类的象征意义。这使它们成为非常高效的群体标记，如果我们是那个把
month on our hair to perform our purification rituals, then we can be fairly certain that no other group does it and that allows us to discern those who don't belong and also to discern the members of our own group who we're more likely to cooperate with. I love this idea that in some ways rituals transform everyday actions to the realm of the symbolic and so in some ways the causal opacity might look like a bug, but in fact, it's actually not a bug, it's a feature. Exactly. There are actually laboratory studies that have looked at this ability of ritual to make things special. So when they showed people different types of drinks being prepared beverages, in one case, the beverage was served in a pretty straight-up way. In the other condition, it was served up in a ritualized way.
泥土抹在头发上以进行净化仪式的群体，那么我们可以相当确定没有其他群体这样做，这让我们能够识别出那些不属于我们的人，也能识别出我们自己群体中更有可能与之合作的成员。我非常喜欢这个想法，在某种程度上，仪式将日常行动转化到了象征领域，所以在某种程度上，因果不透明性看起来像是一个漏洞，但事实上，它其实不是漏洞，而是一个功能特性。完全正确。实际上有实验室研究探讨了仪式使事物变得特殊的这种能力。因此，当他们向人们展示正在准备的不同类型的饮料时，在一个案例中，饮料是以一种很直接的方式端上来的。在另一种情况下，它是以一种仪式化的方式端上来的。
So perhaps somebody would bow to it or would turn it around three times before consuming it. And then when they asked participants which drink they would prefer, when they asked them which drink thought was better, when they asked them which drink they thought was special, they all picked the ritualized drink. thought was special, they all picked the ritualized drink. So in addition to this opacity regarding cars and effect demitries, you've noticed that rituals tend to have three qualities, repetition, rigidity, and redundancy.
所以可能有人会向它鞠躬，或者在饮用前将它转动三圈。然后，当他们问及参与者更喜欢哪种饮料时，当他们问及他们认为哪种饮料更好时，当他们问及他们认为哪种饮料很特别时，他们都选择了这种仪式化的饮料。认为它很特别，他们都选择了这种仪式化的饮料。因此，除了这种关于因果关系的模糊性之外，德米特里，你还注意到仪式往往具有三个特质：重复性、僵化性和冗余性。
Can you explain what these are? So ritual obviously involves a lot of repetition. Once a day, once a week, once a month, once in a lifetime, but it's always repeated. But even within each particular Ritual performance, there tends to be a lot of repetition. So sometimes people chant on 108 times. Some people will count the rosary and perform repetitive prayers for hours. By rigidity, we refer to the fact that ritual actions must be performed in a specific way. There are actually studies that show that if you try to intervene
你能解释一下这些是什么吗？所以仪式显然涉及大量的重复。一天一次，一周一次，一月一次，一生一次，但它总是被重复的。但即使在每个特定的仪式表演中，往往也有大量的重复。所以有时人们会念诵108遍。有些人会数着念珠，进行数小时重复的祈祷。所谓僵化，指的是仪式行动必须以特定方式执行这一事实。实际上有研究表明，如果你试图干预
and change the way a ritual is practiced, people get morally upset. Now this has actually happened historically. FDR moved things giving by a week, so that the holiday period could be extended and people would spend more money. Now this has actually happened historically. FTR moved things giving by a week so that the holiday period could be extended and people would spend more money. And people were morally appalled. Most states actually refused to enforce it. And they referred to it as Frank's giving
并改变仪式的实践方式，人们会在道德上感到不安。这在历史上确实发生过。罗斯福将感恩节提前了一周，这样假日就可以延长，人们就能花更多的钱。这在历史上确实发生过。富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福将感恩节提前了一周，这样假日就可以延长，人们就能花更多的钱。而人们在道德上感到震惊。大多数州实际上拒绝执行。他们把它称为“弗兰克的感恩节”（Frank's giving），
and it caused an uproar. And finally, the third aspect is redundancy. And this refers to the fact that rituals go well beyond what is functionally required. What I mean by this is that maybe 20 seconds of washing your hands would be sufficient to keep them clean. But in something like a purification ceremony, the relevant rights may go on for hours or sometimes even for days. So besides the fact that rituals have these characteristics, you've conducted studies that find that when people are experiencing setbacks or anxiety or stress, their actions sometimes naturally take on some of the characteristics of rituals. Can you explain the study for me please? We brought people inside a laboratory and we wanted to see whether inducing
这引起了轩然大波。最后，第三个方面是冗余性。这指的是仪式远远超出了功能上的需求。我的意思是，洗手20秒可能就足以保持清洁。但在净化仪式之类的活动中，相关的仪式可能会持续数小时甚至数天。除了仪式具有这些特征之外，你还进行过研究，发现在人们经历挫折、焦虑或压力时，他们的行动有时会自然而然地带有一些仪式的特征。你能为我解释一下这项研究吗？我们把人们带进实验室，我们想看看在这种情况下诱发
anxiety in that context would lead them to perform more ritualized behaviors. And what we found, we used motion trackers to quantify the movement of these people. And as they became more anxious based on a task that they had to perform, their behaviors spontaneously became more ritualized. So they started performing the same actions again and again and again. And I think what that tells me is that when you think about how rituals evolved, it may well be that they actually evolved through these mechanisms where people were naturally turning to some of these systems in moments of stress and anxiety and then over time,
焦虑是否会促使他们表现出更多仪式化的行为。我们发现，我们使用动作追踪器来量化这些人的运动。随着他们在必须完成的任务的压力下变得越来越焦虑，他们的行为自发地变得越来越仪式化。所以他们开始一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地做同样的动作。我认为这告诉我们的是，当你思考仪式是如何演变的时，很有可能是它们实际上是通过这些机制演变而来的：人们在压力和焦虑的时刻自然而然地转向其中的一些系统，然后随着时间的推移，
those behaviors get codified. That's exactly what I think that happened, that ritual evolved as a sort of mental technology that helped individuals cope with all kinds of anxieties, and then was co-opted by groups, by cultures, who then transformed into a very important social technology. We discussed earlier how when people are engaged in a ritual, they often feel as if they are part of a larger organism. You felt this way when you were in the soccer stadium with your dad, the people at the fire walking ritual in Spain felt the same way. Is the reverse true as well when people do things in synchrony?
这些行为被编纂成了法典。这正是我所认为发生的情况，仪式作为一种精神技术演变而来，帮助个人应对各种焦虑，然后被群体和文化所同化，接着演变成一种非常重要的社会技术。我们之前讨论过，当人们参与仪式时，他们常常感觉自己是一个更大有机体的一部分。当你和爸爸在足球场时你会有这种感觉，西班牙走火仪式上的人们也有同样的感觉。当人们齐心协力做事情时，反过来也是成立的吗？
Does it change the way they think and feel? Yes, absolutely. And this is one of the reasons why rituals are so powerful. Our brain simply refers that if we move in the same way as other people, then we are more like those people. And we feel more rapport with those people. This has been demonstrated by different studies, one of which we did in laboratory where we induce synchrony. So we have people move either in tandem or with slight variations. You can imagine this as performing a dance, either with somebody who's a good dancer or with somebody who's a bad dancer and
这会改变他们的思维和感受方式吗？是的，绝对会。这也是为什么仪式如此强大的原因之一。我们的脑子很简单地认为，如果我们以和其他人相同的方式移动，那么我们就更像那些人。我们对那些人的亲近感也会更强。不同的研究已经证明了这一点，其中一项是我们通过在实验室中诱发同步性来进行的。我们让人们成双成对地移动，或者带有细微的变化。你可以把这想象成跳舞，要么和跳得好的人一起跳，要么和跳得不好的人一起跳，
sometimes forgets the steps or makes mistakes. And we found that when people moved in synchrony, their endorphin levels were elevated. Now the release of endorphins is related to social bonding. And not only that, but we found that they liked each other more. They perceived their partners to be more cooperative and they trusted each other more. And we see this not just in the self-reports, but also in their behavior in a trust game,
他们有时会忘记舞步或犯错。我们发现，当人们同步移动时，他们的内啡肽水平会升高。现在，内啡肽的释放与社会纽带的建立有关。不仅如此，我们还发现他们更喜欢彼此。他们觉得自己的搭档更有合作精神，彼此也更加信任。我们不仅在自我报告中看到了这一点，在他们在一个信任游戏中的表现中也看到了这一点，
where they actually have to trust each other with real money that they could be putting in their pockets. And of course this now makes perfect sense why you would have so many rituals built around music and chanting, especially in group settings. Absolutely. Dancing and singing and chanting, those are some of the most primordial ways of for human beings to connect. And you find them in all kinds of contexts, and especially ritualized contexts. One of the things that you say is that high arousal rituals that stimulate many of our senses at the same time, that these high arousal rituals can produce some of the most powerful effects
在这个游戏中，他们实际上必须用真金白银（本可以放进自己口袋的钱）来互相信任。当然，这就完全说得通了，为什么会有那么多围绕着音乐和吟唱建立起来的仪式，尤其是在群体环境中。绝对的。跳舞、唱歌和吟唱，这些是人类建立联系的最原始的方式。你在各种情境中都能找到它们，尤其是仪式化的情境。你所说的一点是，能够同时刺激我们多种感官的高唤醒度仪式，这些高唤醒度仪式可以对我们的情绪状态和记忆产生一些最强大的影响。
on our emotional states and memory. What do you mean by this, Dimitris? One way in which they do this is by creating this powerful episodic memories that become a part of our autobiographical self, the very sense of who we are as a person. So some of your episodic memories may involve the first kiss or the time
德米特里，你这是什么意思？它们做到这一点的一种方式是创造出强大的情景记忆，这些记忆成为我们的自传式自我的一部分，成为我们作为一个人到底是谁的核心感觉。因此，你的一些情景记忆可能涉及初吻，或者你发现自己身处战役中的时刻，或者你的房子被烧为平地的时刻，所以它们可能是你生命中最重要的时刻。而这些时刻通常涉及大量的精神唤醒。仪式通过将人们置于表现出极高唤醒度的情境中来利用这一点，并且他们是集体做到这一点的。因此，当我分享同样激动人心的时刻时，当我与你一起哭泣时，当我与你一起欢笑时，当我与你一起处于危险或痛苦之中时，感觉我们本质上就像兄弟一样。当然，其中的一个含义是，时刻越重要，可能需要越盛大的仪式来标记那个时刻，因为
you find yourself in battle or the time your house burned to the ground so they can be some of the most important moments of your of your life. And those moments typically involve a lot of emotional arousal. Richels use this by by putting people into situations where they exhibit very high arousal and they do this collectively. So when I share the same exciting moments, when I cry with you, when I laugh with you, when I'm in danger or in pain together with you, it feels like we are essentially brothers. One of the implications of this, of course course is that the more important the moment, the more extravagant the ritual might need to be in order to mark that moment, because of
为了具有这种高度的仪式意义感而精心设计的时刻，在我们的头脑中将被视为更具合法性、更重要、在情感上更显著。完全正确。这就是为什么，举个例子，你会发现国家仪式往往非常宏大。事实上，特别是那些与领导人有关的国家仪式，如果这些领导人的大众合法性较低，像国王和独裁者这样的领导人，他们往往会有更精致、更奢华、更浮夸的仪式。这是因为这些仪式增加了他们迫切需要的权威感。我想知道你是否能告诉我某个特定的夜晚，
course moments that are engineered to have this heightened sense of ritual significance are going to be seen as more legitimate, more important, more emotionally salient in our minds. Exactly. And this is why, for example, you see that state rituals tend to be very extravagant. And in fact, particularly state rituals that have to do with leaders who have less popular legitimization, leaders like kings and dictators, they tend to have more elaborate, more lavish, more flamboyant rituals. That's because those rituals add to that sense of authority that they so desperately need. I wonder if you could tell me about one particular night,
当你第一次亲身体验到仪式的力量时，你当时在毛里求斯进行实地步行，你在一个沿海村庄住了好几个星期，准备观察年度的走火仪式。有一天，你站在神庙附近，注意到一些当地人在热烈讨论，并不时朝你的方向看过来，最后其中一个人，即神庙主席把你叫了过去。他说了什么？所以这是一个习惯，当地的神庙主席
when you got to experience the power of rituals firsthand, you were conducting field walk-in Mauritius, and you'd been living in a coastal village for a number of weeks preparing to observe an annual fire walking ceremony. And one day you were standing near the temple when you noticed some of the local men engaged in lively discussion and every so often they would look in your direction and eventually one of them, the temple president called you over. What did he say? So this was a practice that the local temple president
当我被他叫过去时，他说：“德米特里，你跟我们一起生活多久了？”我说：“几个月吧。”他说：“好。所以你现在是我们的一员了。”我立刻知道他叫我过去不是为了对我说这个。我说：“嗯，我不想假装是你们的一员。”
and when he summoned me there, he said, the metrics you've been living with us for how long now? And I said a couple of months, I said, right. So you're one of us now. And I merely knew that he hadn't called me there to tell me that. And I said, well, I don't want to pretend to be one of you.
“我是来了解你们的传统的。”他直接打断了我。他说：“好吧，所以你也应该走火炭。”我对这个要求感到震惊，因为在世界上我开始走火仪式的其他地方，这是不允许的。这是只有当地人才能做的事情，这些人要么祖籍来自这个村庄，要么属于这个宗教。我的第一反应是礼貌地拒绝。我说我不想
I'm here to learn about your traditions. And he just cut me off. He said, well, so you should also do the firewalk. And I was stunned by this request, because in other parts of the world where I started fireworking rituals, this would not have been allowed. This was something only for the locals, people had either drew their ancestry from the village or were part of this religion. My first reaction was to politely decline. I said I don't want to
假装是你们的一员。对我来说，记录这个仪式非常重要。所以在那个日子里，我必须拍照和做笔记。而普拉格（Prager）又打断了我。他说了一些类似于“如果神希望你这样做，你就会去做”的话。对此我回答说：“相信我，普拉格的神才不想让我走火炭呢。”好吧。那么当时你戴着研究者的帽子，正在观看火的仪式展开。告诉我接下来发生了什么。
pretend to be one of you. It's very important for me to be able to document this ritual. So on that day I'll have to take pictures and take notes. And Prager's got me off again. And he said something like, if God wants you to do it, you will do it. To which I responded, trust me, Prager's God does not want me to walk on fire. All right. So then you're wearing your researcher hat and you're watching the fire ritual unfold. Tell me what happens next.
我得到了许可，可以进入所有走火者所在的警戒区，因为我要拍照。我正透过相机镜头看，所以我不知道周围发生了什么。仪式本身太迷人了，以至于我完全沉浸其中。气味、火的颜色以及每个人都在进行的吟唱，所有的沙克蒂（Shakti，译注：印度教中的能量女神），当人们一个接一个地穿过火海时，他们脸上的表情，在某个时刻，实践者拍了拍我的肩膀。我抬起头说：“什么？”他说：“站起来。”我站了起来。他说：“转过身去。”我转了过去。我站了起来。我说：“转过身去。”
So I had permission to be inside the enclosure where all the fire workers were, because I wouldn't take photos. And I was looking through my camera lens, so I didn't know what was happening around me. And the ritual itself is so captivating that I was completely immersed in this. The smells and the color of the fire and the chance everybody's having all the Shakti, as people were crossing the fire one after the other, the emotions in their faces, and at some point, the practice stopped me on the shoulder. And I looked up and I said, what? And he said, stand up. And I stood up. And he said, turn around. And I turned up. I stood up. I said, turn around.
然后我转过身去，意识到整个村庄都在看着我。我正对着火，每个人都期望我走过去。德米特里，你做了什么？在那一刻，别无选择。我显然不想侮辱我的主人。在最后关头退缩也是一种羞辱。我当时唯一来得及说的话是：“请帮我拿一下相机。”然后我转过身，面对着人群。
Then I turned around and I realized that the entire village was looking at me. I was facing the fire and everybody expected me to walk across it. What did you do to matches? At that point, there was nothing else to do. I obviously didn't want to insult my hosts. It would also be humiliating to back out at that very last moment. All I had time to say was, please hold my camera. And then I turned and I faced the crowd.
老实说，迈出第一步是非常可怕的。但一旦你做出了承诺，你的身体就会带着你走过去。但一旦你做出了承诺，你的身体就会带着你走过去。你当时是一个知道煤炭温度可以从750度到1500华氏度不等的人。当你踏上火炭时，你脑子里在想这个吗？当然，当你面对这样的火时，你不可能不知道你踩在温度足以熔化金属的表面上。而且你确实能感觉到。你能感觉到自己，你的脸正在被那股热浪炙烤。我见过人们走过那火。我看到火星从他们的脚上飞溅出来。我想知道同样的事情会不会发生在我身上。
And to be honest, taking that first step was very scary. But once you've committed, your body just takes you across. But once you've committed, your body just takes you across. Now you were someone who knew that the temperature of the coals could range from 750 degrees to 1500 degrees Fahrenheit. Was that going through your mind as you stepped onto the fire? Of course, when you're faced with a fire like that, you cannot be unaware of the fact that you're walking on a surface that is hot enough to melt metal. And you actually feel it. You feel yourself, your face is getting roasted by that heat. And I've seen people go across that fire. I've seen the sparks fly off their feet. I was wondering whether the same thing was going to happen to me.
我见过有人在走火中受伤，所以这个想法确实在我的脑海中闪过。但我只是迈出了第一步，就像人们向我描述的那样，你的大脑完全是一片空白，除了你和火什么都没有。当你穿过炽热的煤炭时，你会进入一种研究人员称之为“心流”的模式。在这种状态下，你的周边视觉几乎消失了。所以你看不到任何人。只有你和火。
I have seen people get hurt through the fire working, so the thought certainly crossed my mind. But I just took that first step and just like people had described to me, your mind is completely empty, there's nothing but you and the fire. When you're walking through the calls, you go into this mode that some researchers have called flow. And in that state, your peripheral vision almost disappears. So you don't see anyone. It's just you and the fire.
但有一个步骤特别让我觉得这一定会留下水泡。所以我的脚底下可能有什么尖锐的东西，而且很痛。事后确实留下了一个水泡。但当这种肾上腺素激发时，你真的不会担心疼痛。那是你最后才会感觉到的东西。当你到达另一边时，感觉怎么样，德米特里？发生的第一件事是，感觉就像一朵云散开了。所以突然之间你意识到
But there was one step in particular where I just knew this was going to leave a blister. So there was probably something sharp under my foot and it hurt. And it did leave a blister afterwards. But when this adrenaline kicks in, you don't really worry about the pain. That's the last thing that you feel. What did it feel like as you got to the other side, Dimitris? The first thing that happened was that it's as if a cloud has lifted. So suddenly you're aware of
周围的环境又回来了。但我还感受到的是一阵极度兴奋的冲击。这种感觉不仅持续了几分钟，不仅持续了几个小时，事实上持续了好几天。通过如此短暂的参与，那些强大的感觉和情感竟然涌现出来，这让我感到惊讶。这让我开始琢磨，如果我作为一个外部观察者、作为一个人类学家、作为一个访客、作为一个来到这个社区的客人，如果我通过这短暂的参与行为体验到如此强烈的情感，那么对于一个在这个社区中长大的人、对于局内人来说，这会有多么强大。对他们而言，这个仪式具有与千年传统相连的深远意义。德米特里·齐加拉塔是康涅狄格大学的人类学家。他是《仪式：看似无意义的行为如何让生活变得有价值》一书的作者。
your surroundings again. But what I also felt was this jolt of exhilaration. The last it not just for a few minutes, not just for a few hours, but in fact for several days. And I was amazed at all those powerful feelings and emotions that came through such a brief moment of participation. That got me wondering, if I, as an external observer, as an anthropologist, as a visitor, as a guest in this community, if I come to experience such strong emotions through this brief act of participation, how much more powerful would that be for a person who grew up in the community, for the insiders. For whom this ritual has a deep meaning connected to a thousand-year-old tradition. Dimitri Sikalata is an anthropologist at the University of Connecticut. He is the author of Ritual, how seemingly senseless acts make life worth living.
德米特里，谢谢你今天和我一起参加《隐藏的大脑》。这真是一段非常愉快的经历。谢谢你。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、安妮·墨菲-保罗（Annie Murphy-Paul）、克里斯滕·王（Kristen Wong）、劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。本周的阿鲁恩·桑基罗（Arun Sankiro）是一位名叫阿尔温德（Arvind）的听众。他是《隐藏的大脑》的财务支持者。
Dimitri, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a real pleasure. Thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Arun Sankiro this week is a listener named Arvind. He's a financial supporter of Hidden Brain.
他告诉我们，他很喜欢在北伦敦的大型绿地汉普斯特德希思（Hampstead Heath）散步时收听节目。非常感谢你的支持，阿尔温德，也谢谢你带我们一起去散步。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。再说一次，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有用，请尽你的一份力量帮助我们蓬勃发展。访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。
He told us he loves listening to the show while taking walks in Hampstead Heath, a big green space in North London. Thanks so much for your support, Arvind, and for taking us along on your walks. If you liked this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。